[Music]
hey folks gonna do something a little
different today well I say different
I've done this once before which is to
react to one of my own older videos now
last time I did this I did this as a
live I'm not doing that this time I
don't have the spoons to run a to run a
live event around this concept but there
are some of my older videos specifically
in regards to Doctor Who that I thought
would be fun to revisit see how much I
agree with and my general feelings uh
last time I did this I tackled a video
that very much I'm like I'm going to be
embarrassed at what I said and that was
very much the case there's the link so
you can take a look at the last time I
did this this time I'm not sure how much
this will end up being the case there
were a couple of things that I
considered the one I'm opting to go with
and I might do others in the future
we'll see
I'm going to be taking um a look at my
old video four things Doctor Who should
never do and one of the reasons why I
want to take a look at this is I'm
pretty sure at least one if not a couple
of the things have actually happened so
aside from whether or not I agree with
my old self and it is very much my old
self flat cap old setup bad quality
camera the The Works
um besides just seeing whether or not I
agree I can now
assess on the issues that have happened
and whether or not um that actually had
the problems that I said it would so
it's going to be weird for me seeing uh
seeing this face again but here we
go I don't like to be overly dictatorial
towards shows that I like but
yeah know these would all be bad ideas
that's a weak
[Music]
open oh wow so this was in the time
period where I did actually have uh an
opening thing this was made for me by a
fan who's
um username is currently escaping me um
but the he just gifted me this it might
it might have even been put into a
template I don't know but like it it was
good and I liked it and now I've got the
the actual custom stuff that gets that
gets credited at the end of this end of
the things so as of the time of my
recording this my most viewed video is
and has been for a while five things
that doctor who needs to stop doing and
that um was true for a very long time I
finally had a video exceed it last year
and it was the James Summerton video
which like I appreciate how successful
that that thing was but I I I don't love
that it was like I don't feel like I
made a drama video however the video was
boosted by the fact that there was a lot
of drama going on and I I feel weird
about that but yeah that video uh five
things doctor who needs to stop
doing that stayed as my top viewed video
for a long time and I actually
considered doing that as my reaction I
opted for this one but maybe if this
goes well we'll do that one at another
time and I have kind of felt like I am
overdue to sort of look at the other
side of that uh that video obviously
hold on let's let's go over the the look
a little bit here so we've got we've got
as close to masculine frames as as I was
doing at that particular Point we've got
the flat cap we've got oh that's a house
Tye R necklace we've got the scarf of
course which I still use that's hanging
up over there actually the flat Cap's
over there there too I just don't use it
very much anymore um as far as the setup
pretty much all this stuff is still in
the background well not all of it not
the gaming consoles and not hewig uh
anymore for reasons I shouldn't have to
explain but most of this is still in the
background of my setup just along with a
heck of a lot more stuff as you can tell
from the title talked about things that
doctor who has been doing that I wanted
it to stop this one um you might think
the flip of that is me saying things
they should definitely do except I don't
have as firm a thought about what I
think the show should do I mean there
are characters I'd like to see come back
I've done you know some stuff um
revolving around that and there'll be
some more like that but this time that's
actually much still the way so like at
this point I have a
tendency um you know that I I lump this
all I lump all this sort of stuff
together I I don't do a lot of dictation
of what something should do in the
future and I don't do a lot lot of
theory crafting I don't do a lot of lore
stuff I don't do a lot of um you know
making guesses and predictions about
what's going to come in the future
partially because it's just not how my
brain works um I'd rather just see what
somebody actually makes and then respond
to that every now and then like I'll
have expectations built up like oh I
hope they do this but I tend to not take
it from the angle of well they should do
this at at least not before I see it
sometimes after I see something I'll go
boy they should have done this but I try
not to do that Advance uh and it's easy
to try because like I said my brain
didn't really work that way that was the
case then it's the case now something's
never changed
despite all that has visibly changed I
want to talk about four things I don't
ever want the show to do y4 and not five
cuz I couldn't think of a fifth that I
actually cared all that much about and I
don't like to pad my lists so we're
going to and we're going to start with a
spin-off on galif
fray okay I forgot I actually
legitimately forgot this was a thing
that people were asking for at one point
I don't think it really is
anymore maybe partially because galif FR
has been destroyed but I think also like
people are still calling for spin-offs
absolutely um um but these days like
they're like bring Torchwood back or you
know give us a spin-off on unit and uh
either expectations that that is what
they'll get or saying that's what they
want I don't remember the last time I
heard somebody pitch uh a galif FR
spin-off but that that was a thing I'd
hear back then intermittently wow I
forgot about that I have talked before
about how I generally don't like things
set on gal ofray in the first place
because the e either due to the
limitations of the budget and what they
can realize or to the limitations of the
imagination of the writers it always
ends up demystifying the place it
always I generally still agree with this
um this this has continued to be an
issue for me like I don't think I'm as
hung up on it as I used to be just just
in so far as like I accept this is a
thing that happens every now and then
and I can't change it but I it I don't
like it I think honestly the strongest
the time lerts have ever been as a
presence was their very first appearance
uh at the end of War games because we
knew almost nothing about them it was
like holy crap but the more we learn
about
them they're less interesting to me and
I'm not going to say there's no good
material that's come out of that there
is a value in in taking a society that's
kind of been elevated to a point of
mysticism and and taking them down a few
pegs and pointing out No actually
they're kind of Petty and bureaucratic
and they're they're not all that I'm not
going to say there's no value in that I
would just kind of rather know less and
when it gets the more granular it gets
the more those kinds of details bug me
like it's like stuff in hellbent like
why is there a barn what why are there
these galif Frans dressed like its
Little House on the Prairie what are we
doing or uh The Deadly Assassin the um
the news reporting really bug me it's
just a guy talking to a camera like you
couldn't come up with a weirder more
alien way for them to distribute
information it's just it's just the same
way we do it it just shows a lack of
imagination and that lack of imagination
makes them seem more pedestrian and to
me that makes them less interesting
always ends up making it seem really
mundane we go to galif fray on things in
episodes like The Deadly Assassin and
look at that they have public television
and news announcers that's weird
and like like it's just so mundane it's
so terrestrial it's so of our world I
want a sense of otherness of alienness
of being way I'm not necessarily better
but like beyond the sorts of things that
you and I do here on
Earth so yeah pretty much the same you
know what's one of the weird things
about watching myself uh my older stuff
this is unscripted like even Beyond just
me knowing that and kind of remembering
how I was working at this point in time
like I can tell it was
unscripted and I think I've gotten
better uh at talking unscripted I don't
think this is bad but there are moments
and pauses to gather thoughts that are
way longer than I would leave in now uh
these days it these days first of all it
happens less often or at least I think
it does um but when it does I'm GNA do
something to cover that and clip that
moment where at least me I feel like I
see the buffering symbol in my eyes for
hot second I'm like processing
processing there's the thought and it's
it's weird to watch that in action um
because I'm not gonna say it never
happens damn it we'll see whether I cut
that um I'm not going to say that it
never happens anymore but it it feels
like something that happened a lot more
back then or at least watching it I
certainly I'm more self-conscious of it
and we almost never get that or you know
like hellbent they've got they've got
barns same examples like made of wood
and a chunk of their population dresses
like his Little House on the Prairie
what
so clearly I held on to those
specific examples and
thoughts some stuff gets
ingrained there's my initial gut
reaction to look almost never do when we
get more information about galif Fray
does it do anything other than make you
go oh well that's really very ordinary I
mean galif Fray and the time Lords
generally are at their best the less we
know about them when they showed up
again in the end of time you know we got
a sense of the threat but they still
felt otherworldly they felt big it was
actually fairly reminiscent of their
first official appearance as a society
in the war games the second doctor's era
where we knew almost nothing about them
and it made them so
intimidating uh but you know I I don't
think you know between not having a heck
of a lot of faith that they're going to
be able to consistently give us
something that isn't just going to
continue to demystify the some of these
sentences i' again that's the stumbling
I'm talking about where I feel like I've
gotten better at talking off the cuff
and talking uh unscripted again I think
for somebody who was going unscripted at
this point in time I wasn't bad like on
the scale of folks who who tend to do
this but I think I'm a lot better
now and also looking at things like
Krypton you know I I don't I don't think
there's anything good to be mined out of
this because again like I said they Gala
Fray works best the less we know about
it and then I I'm going to double down
on this and say it would be even
worse if it was like a prequel dealing
with the doctor
like super young in his first
regeneration like before he was even old
enough to look like William so I'm not
sure if this is actually part of the
official list this thought uh I am going
to agree with that as well like this is
this is one of the
so to to take a hot second because this
was shot before the Timeless child
existed um so here's the
thing
overall I really love Joe Martin as a
presence I think she is
fantastic um I had the joy to meet her
last time I went to Gala Fray 1 um which
I'm going to do again uh next month so
if you're at galif Fray 1 say hi um but
for the most part it really still
bothers me the idea of showing us the
doctor prior to when the show started
because he wouldn't have really been the
doctor and knowing what he went through
or what things led him to become this
kind of person is again just going to
make it seem more ordinary so pretty
much the same thought on that although I
have slightly more solidified thoughts
on it because something like that is at
least kind of indicated that a prequel
about the doctor before the start of the
show would now involve all these secret
uh and previously unknown regenerations
yet for some reason the Tardis still
looks like a phone box although um I
suppose it is theoretically possible
that Joe Martin could still fit the
season 2B theory if you're not familiar
with that uh
it okay so it resulted from the uh the
episode the two doctors where the time
Lords basically show up and get the
second doctor and Jamie to take care of
something but the second doctor was
fleeing them he wasn't working for them
so there is a fan theory that I don't
think has ever been confirmed in
official media that there was a period
basically a secret um season oh 6B I
said 2B 6B that there was a secret like
string of stories where that doctor
worked for um the the time Lords and
then was put back in his memory wiped
now having that be Joe Martin would be
weird because they'd have to like roll
back the Regeneration and turn him back
into Patrick turn her back into rather
Patrick trouton but like they still
could feasibly theoretically work that
in but if she is in fact meant to be
pre-heart old there's again there's just
a whole mess from that like that would
be awful yeah like you no never never
ever ever ever do that I mean never do
like a GFR spin-off in the first place
really double never ever do that because
it it runs into the classic prequel
problem you can't actually develop the
character very much if at all and even
if you do develop it's got to be in a
very rigid way because he cannot end up
more developed than how he was when we
started following him in the actual
Doctor Who show which means you either
have to have him have no development or
have it be really slow or you've got to
have him start out so far away from what
we recognize him as that he can
eventually get there over the Long Haul
and it's just it's going to be painful
it's not going to work and and again I
don't think demystifying the doctor to
that degree is a good idea either either
so number three okay so that was not
officially part of the
countdown and I know a lot of you are
going to disagree with me on this but
hear me
out never make the doctor
Ginger I think this one was my Petty
throw away
[Laughter]
one I'm serious I'm not joking at this
point it has become such a running thing
of the doctor wanting to be Ginger not
becoming Ginger that if they ever do
it I think it needs to be the very last
incarnation of the show if not like the
see I say that I'm not joking I think I
kind of
what to my memory of this and this was a
while back this one was kind of a joke
but I treated it as ser ious which I
think I recognized even as I said this
that this didn't matter but I talked
about it like it did I'm not going to
say that this was not a genuinely held
opinion at the time I think it was but
to see this presented so seriously
instead of acknowledging it for the
silly throwaway notion it was is very
weird it feels incredibly performative
and actually it's a little it's I hope
this section is short this is going to
be hard for me to watch just sort of
getting the sense of you don't care as
much as you're acting like you care and
I like to think I well I generally
definitely don't do that now and i' like
to think I didn't do that a lot back
then so on the occasions that I run into
it it it's it's
weird very last episode like like the
show's ending and we have the doctor
regenerate into a form that it's
presumed goes off and continues to have
Adventures past the the running of of
the TV show like have that one being
Ginger fine cuz at this point I treat
the doctor becoming Ginger like the will
they won't they relationships in most
other TV shows at what point do those
shows go downhill when you answer the
question of will they won't they because
first of all the answer is always yes
they will but when you eventually get
them together the entire Dynamic changes
and you lose a big part of the oh well
okay they did why am I still
here I mean I don't disagree with that
assessment of will they won't they it it
often some things some things can make
that jump to oh well they are and
they're together now and to shift the
dynamic and have it work and and
actually in some shows um because it's
mostly a show thing because in the
course of a movie yeah of course they're
going to get together um and you can't
string it along past the run of the one
movie but when it comes to to shows
there are a handful that I think have
shifted that dynamic in a way that
actually refreshed the show
but again that is that's a weird
comparison to make when you're just
talking about hair
color this is weird and not that I'm
saying the doctor trying to become
Ginger is that fundamental to the makeup
of the show I'm not trying to oversell
that but it's it's of that same nature I
don't think that I think that the
continued frustration that he has at not
being Ginger is got is going to be more
entertaining than the very brief pop
you'll get by finally doing
it when was the last time they even
brought up the ginger thing it's been a
couple regenerations now it did not turn
into the running gag I think I presumed
it was going to be we've got mavity now
I'll stick in asterisk on this and say
if they ever do make the do Ginger I
really want the reaction to be that the
doctor looks in a mirror goes I'm I'm
Ginger I don't like it and then never
bring it up again okay that I still
agree with I actually legitimately still
think that would be very funny so but I
I really rather they just didn't do it
number
two make the doctor
Earthbound so we'll see where I go with
this uh at the time I can tell you now I
kind of still hold this opinion I don't
think that's something we're actually in
danger of but I wonder if used this as a
springboard to just sort of vent my
frustration with how many stories were
being set on Earth at the uh around the
time that I made this um because I know
that that frustrated me that was one of
the frustrations with especially uh
Clara while like I'm actually a little
bit more of a defender of Danny pink in
that
relationship I will admit to one of the
issues that it does is it means the
doctor has to keep coming back to pick
up claraa which means he has to keep
coming back to ear Earth which means we
have more stor set on Earth and those
get a
little a little repetitive for me just
kind of on principle like is the Earth
being invaded again come on so I'm
curious to see if I if I present this
here as just a reason to go off on that
and like by taking it to the extreme of
like oh if the doctor was always stck on
Earth boy it'd be really boring because
it's already not great I don't know
we'll see where I go with this I have
not rewat I don't remember the last time
I rewatched this now I know there is
precedent for this most of the third
doctor's era was very terrestrially
locked he almost never went to other
planets and so I I understand there's
precedent for this but I mean there was
also what they were what they were doing
with the show at that point also
basically they wanted to make the doctor
more like James Bond you know they shoot
more locations they they don't have to
build as many big elaborate sets they
still do some but you know they could
just film something in a field that's
why he did the venutian iido that's why
the master was like a bond Villain Like
that's why the doctor had a car and G
and you know the the gadgets like the H
mobile like that is why all that stuff
was was there to give it more of a James
Bond flavor but it then moved off from
it and at this point especially for how
long the show's been around
I what but a big part of what I love
about Doctor Who is the breath of
possibilities is the fact that they he
can go or he she I I have to get used to
that now that the fact or I'll just say
the doctor as of as care as I can and
avoid the gender terms that the doctor
can go anywhere and any when I love that
breath of
possibilities I don't I like and I've
seen more than a few people float the
idea of maybe with jod Whitaker's first
season because it it looked like
possibly the Tardis kicked her out that
maybe her whole first series is going to
be like trying to reclaim the Tardis and
she'll be stuck on Earth and oh my God I
hope not they never really did address
the Tardis literally tipping over and
dropping
her that's just a thing that happened
that never came
back
that kind of was an early indicator chel
was fond of doing stuff that felt like
it was meaningful and then just moving
on and not doing anything with it very
weird time in Doctor Who so that's the
timeline for when this was I didn't
check when I made this um so it was
after Whitaker's casting but before
series 11 had started
okay I hope not I don't want the show to
be that limited for that length of a
period of time and that's not even me
saying that it's impossible to get good
stories out of of that but I would also
argue that anything that you get out of
doing a long form ter terrestrial Brown
story I.E the more character um sort of
progression and dynamic growth or
whatever like between the doctor and the
companion or the doctor and other
Supporting Cast you can still get that
and having them move to different
locations and times and planets and
stuff and you could still write that
same stuff in being Earthbound makes you
have to do that because you don't you
don't have you can't go off in space for
stuff but that's that's not making it
Earthbound and restricting it is not the
only way to be able to do that kind of
stuff you can still do that without
making the show Earthbound I just don't
I don't like those kinds of excessive
restrictions being put on the show
because this show appeals to my inner
nine-year-old
so this definitely isn't something that
I would say now because I don't think
it's I think the reason this was
probably on my mind was because of the
way that uh the Regeneration happened
people were floating that idea at the
time that it would take a while for the
doctor to get the Tardis back and um so
I think this was a very there was a very
limited window where this was a concern
because you know by the end of the first
episode of series 11 they're literally
floating in space and by the end of the
second episode they've got the Tardis
back so this was this was a a fear that
had a very limited window to exist in
but uh
yeah I I guess it was on my mind at the
time
I it I do feel like uh again in terms of
the presentation I'm leaning into the
into presenting this as frustration more
than I would now like that's not to say
I don't get frustrated but it's again
this feels slightly performative
slightly overblown for something that
I'm worried might happen I generally if
I get annoyed at this point to anything
along the lines of how I sounded talking
about that it's about things that have
happened not things that might happen I
try not to expend my frustration energy
on things that have not even
happened the you know the part of me
that wants to just make believe anything
and the fewer possibilities they are
sort of the less interested I am so I
know this is an idea some people want
and I've seen the idea floated I really
don't want the show to do this one
though I'm not sure how many people
actually wanted it to happen or versus
people just speculating that it might
given the The Dumping of of jod out of
the
TARDIS I'm pretty sure I know what this
and finally number one pretty sure I
remember
what like some of these I I will grant
it is there's like vaguely possible
there was ever so slight sliver of a way
that it can be made to work this one no
I'm drawing a hard line on this no comes
here it
comes the Doctor Who TV show should
never
ever have the doctor regenerate into an
actor that has already played the part
oh boy this is the big one because
yeah yeah they did it and this was not
the only time I went on record saying it
was a bad idea I went on record later
when uh people were floating it towards
the end of Whitaker's run I said no
don't do that that's a terrible idea and
then they did it and I boy I was real
real nervous I'll talk about how it
panned out once they actually did that
in a minute let's let's let him continue
and see how he's going to formulate this
thought uh apologies if it's overly
anger in
tone now couple things I have to point
out about this one I do know that Canon
wise in the show they have opened up
that possibility due to to Tom Baker's
appearance in The Day of the Doctor
which is not something I was against I
still like that but what I liked about
that is because obviously they're not
going to cast Tom Baker again in this
part but what I liked about it is to me
that just implied the endlessness of
this show because we will actually never
see the character ever regenerate into
this actor again CU like I said he's
never going to play the part again which
means we're never going to reach the end
which means Doctor Who effectively goes
forever even if the show ends again we
will never truly reach an end point for
this character that's why I was in favor
of that scene aside from the fact that
Tom Baker was just wonderful and
delightful so I know it came up a lot in
the comments on my review of the giggle
where people said that they think part
of the thing with the bu generation
means that the tenant uh doc the second
tenant doctor 14th doctor is going to
eventually become the curator like
suppose
possibly the reason I'm disinclined to
believe that is that shy got to me at
least shudy got was lines about how
therapy was being done out of order and
he seemed to be very light and
unburdened with the implication being 14
is going to work through his
stuff and then um 15 gets the benefit of
that even though they're technically
existing concurrently to me that implies
that for is either just going to die or
when he regenerates it's somehow going
to involve a remerging with um shiga's
doctor it didn't suggest to me that he
is going to con he's going to have his
own
regeneration uh line parallel I'm not
going to say it's impossible to do it to
do that but that was not my read on how
it worked out but by implying that Tom
Baker was a later regeneration of the
doctor it opens up the possibility
that Matt Smith could come back David
Tenant could come back you know any of
the living doctors feasibly but I mean
realistically those would be the two
that people would be clamoring for at
least at this point people were
clamoring for David Tennant
especially and I I think that more than
anything else more than any of the other
things I've I've named more than almost
any that I can think of would be the
death Nowell
of this show because that would be a
point at which the very Doom and Gloom
very Doom and Gloom show would cease
evolving the show would
stop trying to be anything other than
fan service because the instant the show
does and this show already can get very
tied up in its own history and
continuity and minutia sometimes
decently sometimes to his detriment
but doing something like that having
Matt Smith or David Tennant or
Christopher eglon or any previous actors
played the part be the doctor again well
eckleson he's he's not coming back we
got big finish we'll be happy with that
not like here are some extra Adventures
you didn't know about but like at the
end of jod Whitaker one she regenerates
into Matt
Smith that might be the thing that would
make me stop watching Doctor Who because
at that point remember I said about
breadth of possibilities Endless
Possibilities at that point so it's
interesting
because I it's it's odd it's odd to hear
an older version a uh a previous
regeneration of myself even talk about
like oh if they did this I'd stop
watching because that's just not my
perspective at this point my perspective
at this point is oh boy they did
something that I think is a terrible
idea
boy I hope they can pull this off and do
something with it that I couldn't figure
out what it could be that would be worth
it that's what I hope at like
preemptively dropping Doctor Who or any
show because of like uh a a turn where
I'm I at this point I'm defitely like
let's see where they go with this but I
will be nervous so I if I ever drop
Doctor Who it's got to be be because of
something it does not something you when
I say something it does like over time I
have a hard time believing there'll be a
there could be a single thing like it
does this one thing and I'm out more a
case of like okay well it's done this
and this and this and this and I'm just
tired that
maybe you know but this kind of declared
a statement that's weird for me to hear
that feels like a bigger restriction on
possibilities than anything else and
what I mean by that is the show is no
longer looking forward it is only
looking back it will be only looking
into its own history it'll only be
gazing into its own Naval it is a
regressive move it is it would be a
deliberate attempt to try and be
something that it was before instead of
figuring out what it can now
be so I don't disagree with this General
assessment of the fear how that played
out in practice because spoiler I
actually did end up liking the specials
um star Beast was good and fun wild
Yonder wild blue yonder was great and I
actually really like the giggle
including the bu generation which I did
have to sit on that to be sure what I
thought about it but ultimately I came
around on the thing
is the reason it worked for me was
twofold and these are some things that I
obviously was not taking into
consideration at the time the first
limited run three episodes it it's not
in indefinitely and being positioned as
the 60th anniversary stuff so this is
being positioned as a this is a special
event not this is the new normal so that
helped that was the first thing and then
having actually seen them they did
things that both Ben benefited from the
fact that this specific incarnation of
the doctor um had a pre-existing Dynamic
with Donna and and especially wild blue
yonder really banking on that connection
to get great stuff Great Character stuff
very tense scenes so there was that but
in addition to that also sort of giving
emotional closure to a doctor who didn't
get it the 10th doctor I'm not a huge
fan of his regeneration and like I
understand it as characterization I
understand the hissy fit and the I don't
want to go but I still don't really like
it and for someone like me it's actually
kind of nice the idea that he gets to
come back and have a proper resolution
just just existing a life that he
couldn't not exist that he could not
have if he didn't know there was another
incarnation of him out there doing all
the stuff that he would feel obligated
to do so they actually found a really
beautiful story that you couldn't tell
without bringing back another doctor and
again the limited run helped a lot like
a lot a
lot and Doctor Who has always been a
show that has evolved through the
casting of the doctor through the
changes in Aesthetics through the
changes in the creative team and shifts
and priorities in the writing the show
has always been evolving sometimes for
the better sometimes for the worse and
sometimes they do bring back older
elements and that's fine but when you
literally start putting the old face
back on the character again that's when
there's nowhere forward to go
anymore so again it was handled in a way
that I could not have predicted which
was yes here's the old face to tell a
story uh especially with wild blonder
and the giggle less so with the star
beast but definitely those latter two to
tell stories that would not work as well
if it wasn't somebody that we already
knew
so um now that having been said the
general fear of regressing back to an
earlier point that is a fear that I
still have I expressed that in a video
over on the break room with the fact
that it's very clear Russell T Davis is
just slipping back into his Mystery Box
format of Storytelling on the show and
that bums me out because I'm very tired
of it and I was hoping he would bring
new ideas to the table um and new ways
of going through a series and we'll see
we'll see he surprised me in the best
way with the 14th Octor so we will see
but this General notion of like I I will
start losing enthusiasm when the show
feels like it is trying to recapture
Glory as opposed to um chart A New Path
yeah yeah that's still the case that
that philosophical notion has not
changed now you're just swimming in
Nostalgia and
that might break me if they if this show
ever did it didn't yay and that is why I
think that is the number one thing this
show should never ever do so that's my
list four things that Doctor Who should
not ever do what do you think are some
things they should never do and please
have them be things they haven't already
done don't just be snarky and go oh cast
a woman but they did it like look guys
it happened
okay that was legit frustration right
there it always would bother me like
when people would derail the comments
with that kind of nonsense even back
then so yeah I'm not surprised that I
went like just don't okay can we
not give tell me something the show has
not actually done yet that you think it
should never do what whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it all the
stuff to do like subscribe support me on
patreon follow me on Twitter listen to
my podcast by t-shirt links for all that
stuff is down in the description and
until next time this council is
adjourned so I didn't I wasn't yet doing
the um the outro that I now have not the
full version of it because I I did have
that phrase that you'll hear when I sign
out you're beautiful you are valid you
are loved but I was using it initially
for the ver wild Channel um and then I
started integrating it to the videos
that were specifically lgbtqia plus
Centric and now it's just standard
because yeah it's a sentiment I really
like to end
on um how was I doing the credits back
then oh I remember that
template ah yep um my thumbnail guy Joel
put that together for me I still like
that I I like the I like the the rainbow
of
it that is a short list of patreon
supporters wow I've come a long way um
yeah that was that was kind of a mixed
bag to watch because like there are some
elements that
are that that were performative and
hearing myself kind of stumbled to try
and pick up my thoughts more often or
again at least it feels like more often
that that was uh a little uncomfortable
but this was not nearly as painful as
when I rewatched my video talking about
why the doctor should never be a
woman so this was not that degree of
pain for sure this was a little awkward
though but I am happy to be able to
report back to him you know through
through the Echoes of time hey they did
bring back David Tenant and they
actually did good stuff with it and it
didn't derail the show it's okay and let
the ginger thing go like what what the
heck even was that so yeah that that was
again way less painful than last time
and depending on uh how people feel
about this I might do another uh I could
revisit that five things that doctor who
needs to stop doing video um which as I
said was for a long time the most viewed
video on the channel um so that that
would be probably the top candidate for
me to take a look at again if uh if I do
this sort of thing again but for right
now I think we can uh we can leave it
there so yeah the usual stuff the like
share subscribe what are your thoughts
on my old Notions what are your thoughts
on my thoughts on my old
Notions this gets recursive real quick
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living but
even if he can't help help me out with
that like share subscribe links in the
description but what I really want you
to remember and what I should have been
saying back then
to you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned drum roll for my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Z Lula
goddess Ela Oliver be T roac the thing
that goes dink in the anime Ruth go of
the gazarian solitary pictures olrick
Bogden geek filter Linda Walters Toby
Jackson Jen Auntie Kate 808 Bey Sparks
fori likes the poodle Robin Powell TLO
Cy scrapit angry caspel Dave Hall quite
bearish Rosalyn Bennett pal baraba Jole
and miror G
thanks so
[Music]
[Applause]
much
[Music]
oh